as vote counting got underway it
appeared ferdinand marcus jr was surging
ahead he's the son and namesake of the
former philippine president described by
many as a dictator and ousted in the
1986 revolution i know that the
account is not yet done
it's not just over but i wanted to issue
a short statement
and it essentially is a statement of
gratitude
to all of those who have been with us in
this long
and sometimes very difficult journey
ten candidates are running but for the
presidency it's widely considered a
two-person race
vice president leni robredo who is also
the leader of the opposition is trailing
behind marcus jr
initial results show a lead so wide poll
experts believe it is unlikely robredo
can catch up
i am with you in the belief that the
elections must respect the full voice
and will of the people
it is important that the people continue
their belief and respect for democracy
more than 60 million filipinos voted for
the successor to president rodrigo
duterte in one of asia's oldest
democracies
here in one of the biggest polling
precincts in manila voting day was
marked with frustration about
malfunctioning voting machines
people lined up for hours and refused to
leave even as the polls officially
closed
we want to be here we want to see our
ballots going through the machines and
see the receipts
we refuse to leave our posts this
election is too important and every vote
is sacred
the election commission assures the
public that it is very much in control
and the sanctity of the votes is still
protected
a marcus presidency would mean an
extraordinary return for a family that
was forcibly removed from power three
decades ago through people power and
could become the most consequential
election in recent philippine history
jamal lindogen al jazeera manila